all right gentlemen we all have
sandwiches from our respective stores
and i want to know which sandwich is
your go-to for me it's always this one
tuna and tamago oh [ __ ] my bag got
crushed but
honestly i'm not making this like
appetizing but same joey yeah
you'll notice though the difference
between the family mart and the lawson
sandwiches with especially with the egg
yeah the egg
in family mod is kind of like sliced
event yeah they slice the eggs
fully scrambled and honestly yo this
[ __ ] slaps this [ __ ] is
honestly both of them slap i feel and
what what the [ __ ] this guy this
this uh they didn't have the sandwich
they asked for which is just like a
katsu sando so katsu sando
is literally just like a pork katsu um
just with some
bread slapped on the side and some uh
katsu sauce
okay okay i've always seen those because
they sell those at family mart too
i've never tried them also the genius
japanese packaging you just there's a
little slip that you pull open
and boom it's ready to go everything
falls outwards
like that isn't that amazing that's just
beautiful that is japanese engineering
to the fight
you've got a little picnic for your
sandwiches how do you feel about uh the
lack of crust boys
it's disappointing i mean i mean look at
this right like there's something
missing
it's the bite of the crust yeah it's not
good it's beautiful
it's beautiful do you guys give a [ __ ]
if i just rip some off and hand it to
you yeah it's just here
okay so you try that egg on that's the
real egg okay that's the best look at
the color
look at the [ __ ] bright the
saturation has been pumped to ten
thousand on that you know that [ __ ] this
one's got some slices in it
i've had this one oh that that feels
like a weak bread you know what i mean
they're all weak branches what are you
talking about oh god it's been dunked in
the grease
okay i i don't know how to properly
smear
[Laughter]
oh this cross-contaminated oh no which
which which tomato were you trying first
let's try the family want one so the
one with the slices on it honestly like
what i love about japanese eggs is that
they just have the color in them i don't
know every every japanese egg
just it's like it's it's like they took
the egg the egg yolk
put it in photoshop and turned up the
saturation it looks beautiful
it's like way too yellow for it to be
real yeah i like the egg
the problem i have with this sandwich
sorry i'm eating with my mouth
does the tuna taste like [ __ ] you think
so and this found this sandwich i think
i think the tuna tastes the same
no you'll see what i mean honestly i i
really like the egg i like the egg to be
solid um i love the egg slices yeah yeah
i do like that all right let's try the
lawson egg sandwich then so this one is
no egg slices just fully
mashed okay what i don't like about this
one
and why i've never bought this one is
because this egg looks like runny yolk
it's good try it looks like the [ __ ]
that comes out your nose it's like runny
egg yolk
definitely a lot more of like a
mayonnaise flavor in this yeah yeah yeah
now i prefer to chew on my eggs you know
what and i feel it
you know what i'll give you that one
that that like there is something about
knowing there's like an egg slice in
there that's way more comforting i don't
know i'm gonna try and [ __ ]
dissect this this isn't working
sandwiches were just not meant to be
shared let's be honest
i'm just going to rip it off sorry you
go joey oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
try some real [ __ ] tuna tasting
sandwich action okay can we give me some
of that sandwich
honestly like when it comes to the tuna
it all tastes the same what what
what i want to mention though is that
all the breading for all the sandwiches
in japan
it it's so fluffy it's so light and
fluffy that's why it's
some of my favorite breads i think oh my
gosh i just realized we're breaking
bread guys
like true comrades which one are we
eating first i'm the family
what's the difference there is again
there is no difference no no i can spot
which one
that one's uh okay no that's that's
that's a little
i can tell the difference oh no actually
i don't know
i'm a cool sauce on this one no no no no
no the bread the bread's different
the bread the bread listen listen try it
you'll know what i'm
sure i smell the taste you'll know what
i mean you know honestly
you're you're the mediator in this one
try both of those and tell me if there's
a [ __ ] difference
but it looks different like the family
mart one it's great
no no it's got a weird tinge to it let's
try the last one
okay so this one's a lawson one right
yeah okay let me try both
it tastes the [ __ ] secret oh actually
hold on yeah see you see what i mean
the awesome one's better yeah okay the
lawson one actually tastes like
it's so clean i don't know what it is
man the lawson tuna sandwich
like like it's amazing it's like like
the initial taste i i bit into both and
the initial taste was just like
okay they both taste the same and then
the aftertaste from the lawson's tuna
you actually get a taste
it tastes like fish yeah it tastes it
tastes like fish so if you like the like
the taste of fish i'd say the lawson one
is better if you don't like the taste of
fish i'd say the family want one is
better
yeah i'll give that all right let's try
the now let's try this abomination
honestly there's a part of me there's a
part of me that's thinking this is going
to be good
this is my only strawberry this is this
is i've already got one strawberry as
well i've got
some in mine honestly one thing that the
sandwiches are guilty of doing here is
that they look
loaded in the front they look like
they're filled and then you take one
bite and you realize there's nothing
they click bait yeah it's literally it's
it's literally like the walker's crisp
yeah
where or like it's you bite into it and
most of it's just air and i found that
family mart does that the worst
family martial has this sandwich right
that i used to get from valuable which
is
egg and ham i think and in the front man
it looks like it's bursting it can't
wait to get out and you take one bite
and then you realize that it goes from
like this
it's so thin let's give this a shot all
right
that's not a sandwich honestly it's just
a cake that's just
yeah it's a dessert it's a strawberry
shortcake that's
really [ __ ] weird because you know
what it tastes like a strawberry
strawberry shortcake but then you're
just chewing bread proof that bread
works with [ __ ] anything
no i i that that tastes wrong i'm not a
fan of that i would i would rather just
eat a strawberry
that's that's like the equivalent of
putting
a burger or like putting a patty between
two two bread
two breads uh slices and calling it a
burger yeah
yeah i've always seen those being sold
because i think they sell all of those
at like lawson and seven
yeah they all have dessert sandwiches
[ __ ] the one with like uh i saw one
where was like
uh cream and lime cream oh no no i'm
yeah and i was like that looks [ __ ]
whack one thing i say i will say the
whipped cream they use here in japan
it's s tier whipped cream uh i agree i
whip
cream to me doesn't really [ __ ] taste
like anything i just kind of like you
you taste japanese whipped cream and
you think it tastes like you you taste i
can i can stand that better
i don't like like you telling me that
the whipped cream did not carry what you
just
ate right there because it was like the
bread kind of carrying
get out of here i had like one quarter
of a [ __ ] strawberry there's nothing
happening i used to i used to [ __ ]
despise like
all cakes and stuff like that like
strawberry shortcake i was like nah
that's some boring [ __ ] but then i had
strawberry shortcake here yeah i was
like
oh my god strawberry caught uh i i was
exactly the same strawberry shortcake
here
blew my mind because the the cake part
is so fluffy
and the cream the whipped cream japanese
whipped cream is the best i've tasted
in the world i will i will stand by that
and that's why japanese sweets taste so
good a lot of it